did america
lose its core culture and ideals
by trying to make it so inclusive by
letting everybody
in here where we lost our fabric what
this was founded on because everybody's
like i don't agree i don't agree i don't
agree
so they try to appease and try to please
everybody else that wants to change it
or and then
some of these countries that stayed core
today to their you know what they stand
for russia china india whatever maybe
they're like no this is what we're all
about you don't like it leave this place
versus america's like oh you don't like
it well let us change for you
do you think we've lost a little bit of
our you know what we were founded on or
no
again i think it's a little bit of a
perfect storm i think
i think the one one of the challenges
that we face is you know if you
and i'm speaking now really kind of
about politics uh i believe that you can
define politics in the fighting way you
know politics
is the acquisition or maintenance power
can we agree that's like a general
overarching yeah fire or maintain power
that's what politics is
so there's two ways to do that right you
can unite people which i would argue
like very difficult to do to really just
unite people
um like maybe obama did it in 2008 he
didn't do it in 2012 like you know i'm
just looking for recent examples
or you can do what most politicians do
is they divide people
and the way you divide people is
typically you say you know you see that
group of folks over there
they're the ones who are causing you the
problems they're the ones that you're
supposed to be
afraid of and i'm going to protect you
from them and that's the thing
fear you know fear is how we divide one
another
and so i think so many americans now are
incited
to fear and we have a political class
that continues to incite people to fear
incite them to rage and play on these
emotions because those our emotions are
a way of
not only acquiring or maintaining
political power they are ways of
acquiring or maintaining
cultural power economic power fear
fear fear fear fear it's everywhere and
it's
killing us and so you know have we
veered away i mean you know
uh sure like are there are there people
right now in the united states who are
saying that the democrat
the demographic changes that are
occurring in this nation or a reason to
be afraid
yeah of course and there are politicians
who are making a lot of hay out of that
and then i would argue there are
politicians on the other side who are
making hay
out of people coming here saying you
know you're never going to be accepted
by the united states our country is
fundamentally
and forever flawed with racism and it
doesn't work and it's horrible from its
founding
and that's just you know they're just
photographic negatives of the same image
inciting people to fear
in order to either acquire or maintain
their power
so you just like you got to see the con
like see the con and if you see the con
you don't play into it
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye